about 4 10 in the morning I was still sleeping,
I heard a strong blast wave, I jumped so much on the
bed,
my first thought was that everything was fine alive
then the second thought was about the carcass, the
family was sleeping, so I knocked out the door to me the door was a
little jammed into the room, I knocked out the
door look  on steam and everything is
fine, we all got together then
we heard that the smoke was coming, we wanted everything here, it’s
disgusting, the stairs were already different
Lena, so the decision was made to stay in the
apartment and that’s all
at the moment
and we already have a problem in the tank
more
46 where and the experience is ready,
it is doomed
it happens
sometimes 40 are
bred here,
so the
pants are
definitely drains
if you remember
[applause
] you have you here